let's get into the failures of what's
going on and i'm not gonna uh dwell too
much on the 25th amendment but i did
pull this article i find very funny it's
from vanity fairs hive they said
republicans who stood by a presidential
lunatic are now demanding biden be
removed by the 25th amendment they were
fine with trump trying to overthrow the
us government but insist biden must go i
really love the framing because i i
don't i don't think anyone was fine with
trump overthrowing the government i
think that's just a very unfair way to
look at what was happening
but let's move forward to why joe
biden's being criticized in the first
place we're going to talk more about
what's going on with afghanistan
biden versus reality from the daily mail
president falsely stated that the u.s
has no troops in syria when there are
900 and the afghan military had 300 000
troops in a series of lies and bungled
statements in an abc interview biden
said there was no way to leave
afghanistan without chaos ensuing but
six weeks ago he said a taliban takeover
was highly unlikely he said the u.s
doesn't have a presence in syria but 900
troops remain the president took
questions from the media for the first
time in over a week on wednesday in an
interview with abc's george
stephanopoulos yeah but was he actually
making himself available to all press
in one bizarre moment biden seemingly
brushed off afghani stowaways so
desperate to flee they clung to
departing us plane before falling to
their death and now we've got the white
house chief of staff who apparently is
not doing interviews but is getting
criticized because he's tweeting a bunch
of far leftists on social media you got
john sackey on vacation kamala harris
says i don't want to be talking about
this stuff
man what's going on with this
administration dude
not enough but too much so that's a good
way to put it
i mean this week has been rough for the
body administration and just us as you
know as a country regardless of how you
feel about the war a lot of people feel
like you know
one we should have gotten out of there
but not in the way that we left and
certainly shouldn't uh have left people
who helped us uh behind but even more
importantly definitely not leaving
americans behind so
um that's the craziest thing yeah yeah
yeah we've got 15 000 americans still in
afghanistan and this is one of the
things i kind of
you know when biden said that i think it
was biden who said this right in the in
the interview with with abc that there's
15 000 americans that are still there
they can't get them out because they
can't get to the airport and that kind
of like i had this moment where my heart
kind of went like bump him like big
because i was like
you know what's going to happen in the
next couple of months yeah the taliban
is not going to be like oh american
right this way well you're going to
escort it they're going to be like on
your knees and we're going to start
seeing videos of this stuff
and then
yeah i agree i'm i'm i'm i'm hoping the
taliban is more scared
of losing any kind of international
recognition which i don't think they're
gonna get in the first place and
considering the stuff we're already
seeing out of there it really does feel
like they might try to be like no no
americans we're we're being peaceful you
can go
but
i i don't see them getting the
recognition i guess one of the things
they're saying now is that the us has
accepted saudi arabia and they basically
want to do the same thing so what's the
problem
i don't know though you know i i think
there may be some hope in that they're
scared of the us still and so they're
like just get the americans out of here
but 15 000 how many of them might be
contractors yeah how many of them may
have crossed the taliban in some way and
they're going to be like not this one
and then we start seeing these videos
so why didn't the biden administration
hard mandate evacuate americans before
the withdrawal you know they left bagram
air force base in the middle of the
night they just ran out left everything
wow the conspiracy theory is that they
wanted to make it such a poorly executed
withdrawal that it makes it makes people
want to go back like you see how
horrible it was that makes people want
to go back in later they're doing it
they're sending in more troops whether
or not it's intentional but it's really
really about dude watching the people
fall from the airplane was really really
guttural because i remember
watching the people fall from the world
trade center they were they were hanging
out the window and they jumped out
because they didn't want to burn to
death
and um it's like bookends into this
20 years
that's crazy dude yeah all to get osama
bin laden and they invaded the country
like what they obviously wasn't to get
osama bin laden they didn't have to
invade the country to do that yeah
someone should ask bush what's going on
there's a really great meme where it's
uh
three spider-man you know the two
spider-man meme yeah it's three and it
says you know like biden trump obama
they're all pointing at each other and
george w bush is painting the picture
yeah dick cheney really he was he ran
the military at that point but
halliburton his company what was his
role at the halliburton was either
chairman of the board or the ceo or
something yeah i'll give biden i'll give
mine in this respect because he said
it's in a speech that he didn't want to
pass this this failure off in the next
presidency because that's what obama did
obama obama got it from w bush
and he promised he was going to end all
of this stuff and instead we got more
troops and i think one of the big
reasons was
he didn't want it to happen under his
name he didn't want the failure to be on
him he passes it off to trump trump says
okay we're drawing down i mean it wasn't
it was only it was it was bush obama
trump tr uh so obama receives the you
know he inherits this war
and then it just keeps going he keeps it
going trump inherits it and says we're
ending this now we should have ended it
a long time ago biden says you know what
i'll follow through
he screwed it up
bad
real bad so but but do you think obama
didn't want the failure to be on him or
do you think he was afraid that if he
pulled out of afghanistan we may end up
getting an attack on our soil so he'd
rather fight them there than fight them
here i don't i don't believe that
because the there was this report came
out a long time ago that said one of the
contribute one of the main drivers of
terror in the us is what the cia called
blowback that the us operations in the
middle east over the past several
decades had created the anger and
animosity which resulted in so uh the
targeting of the us so with like the us
funding of the mujahideen and then
meddling in these countries and iran and
things like that you end up with groups
saying they're going to come after us
staying in afghanistan
i suppose it makes sense though because
they're so preoccupied fighting us over
there they don't come over here yeah but
i think that i i we had the patriot act
we buffed up our security we locked
everything down
to still then be worried about it just
goes to show the security measures were
probably pointless yeah
well so so one thing that that this
entire
um
saga particularly over the last week has
made me think about
and i hope it makes other americans
think about is that
democracy is not the natural order of
things
um it's not everyone's default
it doesn't necessarily work in all parts
of the world at all times with all
people
and um i hope it's made americans
rethink what we call oppression
because real desperation looks like
somebody hanging on
to the to the landing gear of a cargo
plane
from afghanistan to wherever they were
going
not you know some hollywood actress
who's pampered who you know somebody
writes the wrong name on their starbucks
cup and they say oh my gosh i'm sorry
or not some athlete who you know sees a
police shooting 4 000 miles away and
they don't have the facts and they say
oh my people are so oppressed
because when life really gets that
difficult
you see what
um desperation will drive people to and
i hope it makes us reassess how we use
language
um i'm tired of living in hyperbole
nation where everything has to be
catastrophized it's like no we can we
can deal with our issues
without using the same words to describe
light inconveniences here that other
people use to describe actual tyranny
over there yeah absolutely dude right on
i mean so many people in this country
think that every slight offense is the
apocalypse they gotta film it someone
someone said a naughty word to me on the
street it's like
i in this country some dude was like
fleeing for his life and you know grip
to a plane yeah you wanna know the
craziest thing about that
uh that dude on the plane he was 19
years old wow there were multiple people
yeah the two people who fell one of them
was a 19 year old kid from afghanistan
and you wanna know why that's crazy he's
younger than the war yeah he does not
know a world in which the taliban was
afghanistan he was born into this
country under us occupation he grows up
in that system and then overnight
overnight within a month it was like a
one month collapse you saw this going
down
and then really escalated at the very
end in the past few days and all of a
sudden you've got islamic militants
something he doesn't understand and
never lived under saying
it's it's this or or or else so he was
like get me on that plane yeah i'll take
the orls
you know a lot of people pointed out
that
these are fighting age young men who
should have stayed and fought
i think that's i think it's half true it
is true they are fighting age young men
they should have stayed and fought the
problem was you know i was reading this
op-ed they said a couple things there's
two different ones the bind
administration pulled air support
as soon as they lost that was the
centerpiece of the military strategy so
the afghan security forces were like
what what do we do now we have no it was
maintenance i guess we have no way to
maintain our air force because we don't
know how to do this and the other was
the aban abandoned bagram like overnight
and so all of a sudden the security
forces are like waking up one day with
nothing and they're like uh
that was like an abrupt massive shift
overnight yeah so all of a sudden
they're overrun they don't got the ammo
they've got the support
yeah
these people do not care about civilian
life they don't even care about their
own military military life they got us
into a war recklessly and got us out of
the war recklessly so many hundreds of
thousands of people have died their
families have been tarnished this 19
year old kid probably knows somebody
that
i think it's for money i think it's for
for for opium i think that's why they
did that is for drugs and uh
oil
i i wouldn't i don't think it's i
wouldn't make it so specific i just say
power that opium trade all of that stuff
was just but i don't blew up in the last
two decades the opium i i agree but the
way i would phrase it is i don't think
they're looking at their their like you
know their their
bottom line and calculating opium i
think they're just like what's the money
right you know who i don't care what
person is worth a hundred grand each or
we'll be civil pet peds civilians pet
ants are worth
60 grand each so if we kill 3 000 of
them that's
you know 1.8 million but we're going to
make 60 million in heroin
so easily that's a good deal for us plus
all the opportunity costs that's gone
when you don't have to feed people i
mean it's it's terrifying that's what
governments have been doing is deciding
who lives and who dies and but they
they're so when they become aggressive
then they create situations where they
have to make that choice but they
created that situation
i could
this is like a deep spiral into madness
for me i'm i'm i mean i
i don't know we're out though you know
what i mean so as much as i can be
really upset with the images we're
seeing and now the potential of these 15
000 americans i still think it was right
to get the troops out and so
it's it's it's a challenge because if
you knew beforehand that biden was a
[ __ ] and we did
and that this would probably be
seriously screwed up and we could all
assume that would we still do it
and
i think the answer is yes however i
think there would have been
there there had to have been some kind
of i don't know man
how did he not listen to any like his
intelligence was bad the admit it's
chaos
so
it's a tough question yeah everything
we're seeing right now i'm curious as to
how
um this experience in the last 20 years
how they will reshape
our politics both domestically and our
foreign policy
i'm curious as to
you know what america's role on the
national stage
what role we want to take in terms of
nation building
you know as the world's policeman i
wonder what the appetite will be for
that from either political party
um
i i think this could be the beginning of
the end
we got we got what like 25k troops in
korea or you know a certain amount in
japan we got soldiers in germany how
long until the this
all this we're seeing results in
americans just being like we shouldn't
be doing this um what if so if we really
do see like a red wave backlash to biden
that results in trump coming back in or
someone like trump and their trump was
saying get our troops out of germany
like why do we got troops in germany
that makes no sense germany's fine they
can handle their own security
what happens when we get a trump was
just like how many of you think we
should be focused on america first yeah
and then you get people just screaming
yes because we're sick of this foreign
foreign intervention stuff yeah
and then what happens
i don't know because i mean it's easy to
say that you bring the troops home
everybody says yes we can focus on our
domestic problems but as you see whether
it's the influence of
china or other countries growing in
other areas people start to say okay
these other countries are not doing the
same thing they are definitely
globalists they want to control parts of
africa and the caribbean
latin america
what is america going to do and how
would we feel as a country if
um
china let's say china's influence grows
to the point where
they are basically everywhere but
you know mexico us and canada is that
something that our politicians would
want to live with um it's easy to talk
about you know sort of a
non-intervention
as a as a you know political exercise
but again when you see the influence of
those countries growing whether china or
russia whoever it is is that something
that we could live with this is the this
is the big challenge so i'm i'm i
usually err on the side of
anti-intervention but we should mind our
own business we should be building up
roads in america we should do these
things because those are the first the
immediate and the obvious you know um
you know problems to address
but then i'll remind everybody you know
and i'm not i'm not trying to say it's
right to invade other countries not at
all but keep in mind
when during the during the cold war you
had the expansion of communism this is
this is despotic authoritarianism they
were massacring people i mean
you look at what's going on what
happened in cambodia you look at what
happened in in southeast asia all across
these countries it was a nightmare
and so the u.s was their their mentality
it wasn't just blindly like we're going
to go to armani it was like if we sit
back
and the communists
keep expanding because they're
militaristic they're taking over
20 30 years it will be impossible to
stop them we either confront them now
or
in 30 to 40 years they surround us on
all sides
look at us and say now you're done and
then they control our trade they control
they influence us and then we fall to
them so the americans didn't want to do
it now with afghanistan it's not the
same thing it's it's not like china's
literally gonna you know
it's not like you know communist
russia's massive expansion but china
does
they are working with the belt and road
initiative they are expanding so it's
probably more strategic and therein lies
the scary question if the us doesn't
have any kind of international presence
do we just wait until china surrounds us
yeah so so ultimately i just at one more
final point to that the u.s was
expanding and surrounding everybody else
they viewed us the way we view them
right now
interesting
the the way you described it
as you were talking about you know
um russia's expansion i said
that's the cultural world we're fighting
um the the groups that are influenced by
you know marxism and leftism of one sort
or another
are always looking for territory to
capture yep
and unless
you know there's pushback from everyday
citizens and and a lot of people look to
the republican party i don't know that
they are astute enough to understand the
game that's being played i say that
because oftentimes they mouth the same
slogans
they they chant the same things they
seem to have the same worldview they
don't understand how they're being used
yep and unless
there is a pushback in 20 30 years
there will be no space left everybody
will either have to be
you know trading bitcoin and and doing
uncancelable jobs right so if you
you know if you trade options or if you
are
investing
it doesn't really matter what your
politics are
but if you have a job in the private
sector and you're one of the people who
says no i don't want to fly the flag i
don't want to put up the the the state
party's uh official slogan you're going
to find life very very difficult for
yourself that's a good point actually
trading you know because it's just you
log in but then what happens when your
bank bans you that's true when your you
know credit card shuts down and or your
social credit score drops below a
certain level
yeah i mean conservatives better start
opening some banks and libertarians yeah
so
i think indicative of a vulnerability in
the system of centralized banking that
any one person would ever have the power
to stop other people from banking yeah
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl monday
through friday at 8pm where you can
leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time